finally opening day has arrived in late
july lucas giolito on the mound and
we'll take a look at 29 starts last year
he was brilliant the white sox think
they are legitimate
contenders to dethrone
the minnesota twins and i'm sure the
twins have a lot to say about that we'll
we'll see i think this series is huge
it's setting the tone
on the first pitch of the season sends
one to right goodbye
picking up right where they left off
kepler on the season's first pitch
sends one out
as much as the white sox wanted to send
a message that sends a message right
back there these twins aren't letting up
from where they would last year the
runner at every base so mitch carver the
batter
on the line to right
chased by del monaco
he makes a catch tagging from third
polanco will score
and it's 2-0
[Applause]
rosario will score and the twins jump
out in front four to nothing
reals the opening day stay a starter
last year when he beat the indians here
at target field getting the assignment
again this year as abreu bats second and
third nobody out first inning two and
two
up the middle hard hit on the ground
arise ranges over and makes a fine play
as the twins do get it out abreu drives
in his first as tim scores and monkana
to third
kepler bass got a first pitch fastball
homer to right to begin the season again
the 2-2 pitch is crushed high and deep
to right field beckett goes deep it goes
and gone kepler amazing
two at bats two homers
5-1 twins
and max kepler's season has gone off to
as good a start as you ever could have
dreamed of here comes the very first
major league at bat
for luis robert considered one of the
best prospects in baseball comes the
first pitch and he lines that one to
left field a base hit
that didn't take very long luis robert
with his first big league hit they go
station to station first and second
nobody out here in the second inning
that's his first big league hit the ball
flipped back to the chicago dugout
and a keepsake for robert
for folks sitting at home who've never
pitched
i'm sure some of them have got to be
saying how do you have that amount of
focus as it gets away
and here comes a run
malloy scores and it's five to two
here's mankato he represents the tying
run two on now in two outs now the
one-two pitch high fly ball deep into
right field hey ed this one's for you
turn on the fireworks it's a tie ball
game light it up johan monkatta has gone
deep and it's a 5-5 game base is loaded
in a tie game 5-5 and jorge polanco will
be the hitter
punched into center
and that'll die for a base hit
ceno will score another run scores and
like that twins back on top 7-5
lady rosario is the hitter polacco at
third cruise at first see what rosario
can get done here
grounded towards the middle and through
for a base hit
polanco scores
just out of the reach of garcia and
rosario gets his first hit and first run
batted in so again the bases are loaded
still nobody out now the twins are
looking to put this baby away swinging a
miss and that's strike three first out
of this seventh inning
strike three called a sinker that was
in the area and two gone
and it's going to be up two louise had
eyes wins eight white sox five seventh
inning and the pitch is swinging a line
drive in the year to right near the line
that's down for a hit
one run is in two runs score garber is
going to make third and stop there arais
delivers yet again
the twin second baseman a two out two
run single twins ten white sox five
i was supposed to yes
robert pumps it into right center field
flying toward the alleyway and off the
base of the wall luis robert has a
two-hit debut
this is a fastball outside
and it just explodes off his back i
think kepler thought he had a shot at it
but it sounds like a cannon going on
with great carry though he's going to be
really exciting
debut
for cody hoyer
he threw the ball very well in the inter
squad games
cody hoyer gets a fly ball to center
field luis robert is underneath and he
makes the catch two debuts robert and
hoyer connecting there swinging in a
miss strike three took a little
something off
i got garber way out in front he was
looking for 97 got 88 and that's out
number two here in the top of the nine
ten five twins
so that baseball his first big league
strikeout do you get a choice of san
diego or boise you pick boise nice
choices
leary garcia with the throw
for round number three
wow
what an outing for stashak a one two
three ninth and the twins in their
delayed 2020 opener
open with a 10-5 win over the white sox